nous vous parlions hier des chiffres de
la sécurité routière en évoquant le
triste bilan de 32 tués sur la route en
indre et loire en 2021 alors pour
apprendre aux conducteurs à mieux
maîtriser leur véhicule mais aussi à
mieux connaître leurs propres limites
des stages de conduite sont
régulièrement organisées dans nos
départements afin d'acquérir les bons
réflexes
l'un d'entre eux avait lieu cet après
midi au parc des expositions de tours
six stagiaires adultes y participer
démonstration dans ce reportage de
tristan rickli et mickaël texier
avec ce système c'est comme conduire sur
la neige s'enchaînent et chercher à
avoir les bons réflexes sans savoir s'il
faut freiner ou non tourné ou non le
volant pas simple de perdre ses repères
de conducteurs chevronnés quand
l'adhérence vient à manquer
ce stage à lui me permet de
de comprendre comment maîtriser mon
véhicule éviter les pertes d'adhérence
et ne pas mais exposés à des situations
encore plus compliqué essayer de gérer
aussi porté son regard parce que là je
viens d'apprendre à reporter mon regard
au bon endroit ce qui me permet de
maîtriser mieux mon véhicule et les
formateurs ne ménagent pas leurs
stagiaires en les mettant en difficulté
il génère eux mêmes les soucis qu'ils
pourraient rencontrer donc là ça va me
permettre de commander soit l'avant soit
l'arrière soit les deux pour décider de
ce que je souhaite travailler ça peut
être d'avoir des mots mes pneus à
l'avant et des bons à l'arrière où l'
inverse par exemple celui qui décide de
mettre des pneus vite vite faut partir
vite dépêche toi vite on va se faire
rentrer dedans il ya un camion qui
arrivait à la satisfaction des
stagiaires du jour conscient du gain que
ce stage leur apporte même si j'ai
bientôt 40 ans de permis et pas
d'accident
malgré tout je suis certain qu'il ya des
situations dans lesquelles j'aurai un
accident c'est sûr et donc c'est un bon
exercice voilà que chacun devrait faire
une petite dizaine de participants pour
ses exercices aujourd'hui à tour
organisé par l'assureur matmut au parc
des expositions pour ceux qui n'y
étaient pas que faut-il retenir si vous
roulez sur route mouillée ou enneigées
d'avoir une conduite qui résonnait qui
réfléchit je vais adapter mon allure
bien observer la courbure et essayer
d'envisager des obstacles si on est
surpris dans un virage toute action
brusques sur la voiture peut avoir des
conséquences donc toujours à des gestes
souples des récits est calme et toujours
avoir un regard sur qu'est ce qui va se
passer plus loin où est ce que je veux
aller à vous de bien jouer